water, earth, fire, air.
you guys are not gonna believe this, team
avatar is back
welcome back everyone
happy new year it's Charlie we have to
talk about the new avatar the last airbender
Netflix series there's new
episodes that are coming they're getting
ready to go into production so we'll
break it all down this will also be my
top 10 moments from the series so if
you're brand new to my channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the Avatar The
Last Airbender videos of course I'll be
doing episode videos for this series but
I'll also be doing bonus videos while we
wait for episodes to get here
I'll think of some fun avatar themed
giveaway to do for my avatar videos in
the future but big things first what's
going on with the new Netflix episodes
so we got that first look teaser of Appa
they did say that Appa was one of the
few things that they were really trying
to nail early in the production process
they've written all the scripts which is
why they're getting ready to start
shooting the script part was actually
the easy stuff because they're adapting
the original episodes just expanding the
original episodes from the 30-minute
format to the hour-long format because
Netflix seasons typically wind up being
between 8 and 13 episodes obviously that
means structurally they'll have to
change the way they plot out book 1 book
2 and book 3 because it would be a super
huge bummer if they had to blow through
all that story in three seasons of only
8 to 13 episodes so the first two years
of the show we'll just be book 1 split
into two halves they didn't say whether
it'd be eight episodes 10 or 13 the
reason why the episode count will
probably be a little bit shorter per
season like say closer to 8 episodes is
because Netflix shows with huge special
effects budgets like Avatar The Last
Airbender will need to have so that they
can do bending right typically have
shorter episode runs The Witcher Netflix
is a good example of that they only did
eight episodes because it's a super
expensive show some of the former avatar
people said that they're shooting the
show in February so I know a lot of you
are like how do I submit myself for
casting because last year Bryan can
yetsko also revealed that they would
have open casting calls so if you want a
chance to star in Avatar The Last
Airbender there would be an opportunity
for that but he hasn't given the details
for that yet and typically you would do
that through Nickelodeon studios but
because this is a Netflix project it'll
probably be through one of Netflix's
companies that it selects for that but
big reminder because
to be as authentic to the original story
as possible they're trying to be
ethnically authentic to what each of the
nations represents especially for the
main characters so for instance the Fire
Nation characters are based on Japanese
characters so the actors who play Fire
Nation characters will probably look
Japanese earth nation is mostly Qing
Dynasty Chinese even though the air
nation is mostly modeled after Tibetan
monks there aren't a ton of airbenders
during the original Avatar The Last
Airbender series because of the genocide
that's why the series is called The Last
Airbender because Aang is very literally
the last airbender until he starts his
own family with Katara in the water
nation are mostly modeled after the
Inuit people it probably won't premiere
until 2021 though there was some
information that people found on
Netflix's website that listed 2020 as
the release date but that just does not
seem realistic most TV series take a
year to turn around especially special
effects heavy TV shows like Avatar The
Last Airbender is going to be so getting
into my top 10 moments from the show
and because they're doing this on
Netflix they're no broadcast standards
they can get way more hardcore with the
versions of these that they do on the
live-action Netflix series so starting
with number 10 egg learns what happened
to the airbenders after he was trapped
in the ice a hundred years ago the air
nomads genocide in the moments before he finds out he has all these flashbacks
thinking about the happy memories that
he's going to try and relive and
reconnect with monk gyatsu but because
he's a child he's forgotten that it's
been a hundred years and most of them
would be dead in present-day anyway even
if they hadn't been killed off during
the war he binds the bones of monk
gyatsu and completely loses it
going into the Avatar state
automatically it's one of the first
times that happens on the show the very
first time he went into the Avatar state
was when he went into the ice a hundred
years ago
and because he hasn't mastered all the
four major bending styles he can't
consciously go into the Avatar state so
when he does Hulk out and go into it
automatically he's not in control of
himself he becomes literally like the
mindless version of the Hulk but number
nine Prince suas death in the end of
book 1 the siege of the north she was a
relatively new character but they did a
really good job of creating a
relationship between her and the other
characters Premier Li Sokka so he
actually did care about her when it came
time for her to
choose to make her sacrifice to save the
moon spirit the whole metaphor being
that the moon spirit gave part of its
life force to save her as a child so she
was effectively returning that gift to
the moon spirit to bring it back to life
number eight Aang is forced into the
Avatar State after general Fung tricks
him into thinking that he killed Katara
so general Fung was meant to be a
different kind of villain or antagonist
however II want to think about him he
was someone who was trying to be a
friend this is a good thing go into the
Avatar State defeat Fire Lord Ozai now
end the war but this was happening way
before he learned to Earthbend or
firebend so he still couldn't go into
the Avatar state at will when he thinks
Katara has died though he hooks out
again and just like the Hulk does he
almost smashes everything in sight until
they bring him back down number seven
Aang meets code the face dealer who
appeared several times on the show and
was creepy in the best possible way
every single time the first time he
meets him and you see all the different
faces - you find that some of the faces
also represent some of the things that
Aang is going to encounter later in the
story like the blue Oni face which is
reminiscent of the blue spirit mask worn
by Zuko there's the face of the owl
which makes you think of Wan Shi Tong
which Aang will encounter later when he
eventually makes it to the library but
also you've learned the tragedy of
avatar Couric's fiance how did Coe wind
up stealing her face so that became a
big question for fans and you also have
to imagine that Coe lied a little bit
about his encounter with avatar Karuk
saying that he'd faced him around 800
years ago when really it was closer to
400 years ago
spirits lie all the time in the Avatar
series number 6 was when Appa got
abducted during book 2 when they were at
the library and forced to go into the
circus not only did it completely mess
aang up but it totally messed up Momo
and the rest of the group Appa gets
stolen by sandbenders when they're at
wan-chi tong's library which obviously
is a whole big thing all by itself
that's a completely separate thing
because the library is sinking into the
sand they're trying to stop it but also
while that's going on Appa gets stolen
and you don't see him for most of the
season once they get to Ba Sing se they
do an episode called oppas lost days
which literally tells you the story of
what happened to him while he's been
gone then it winds up being Zuko to find
him under the lake setting him free
so number
five Zucco gives that the bluespirit
identity and sets Appa free it was one
of the huge turning points for his
character he'd shown signs of maybe
starting to turn good earlier in book
two because Iroh had really started to
enjoy their life at the tea shop
embossing say hey we could have a good
life here why don't you just chill out
and abandon your search for the avatar
your father is probably never going to
love you anyway no matter what you do up
to this point Zuko had been obsessed
with capturing the avatar and reclaiming
his honor thinking that it would finally
make fire lord ozai loved him because
that's really what he wanted his lost
honor for the first couple of seasons
was more of a metaphor for the lost love
between him and Fire Lord Ozai of all
the main characters Zuko has probably
the most tragic backstory which is why
he's one of the best characters in
television history and has one of the
greatest redemption arcs in television
history but number four the story of
how Sukho got his scar so the reason he
was actually scarred was because he was
speaking out against the Fire Nation
generals when they were going to cause a
lot of unnecessary collateral damage to
Fire Nation soldiers during this
upcoming attack but Fire Lord Ozai took
it as an insult to him even though Zuko
wasn't speaking to him directly he was
forced into the Agni Kai to answer for
his perceived insult but then found out
that it was his father he was going to
fight and when Zuko refused to fight him
throwing himself at his feet Ozai
scarred him permanently number three was when aang died for a little while during
the book 2 finale after Azula lightning
bends him while he's in the Avatar state
they had established the rules for how
you kill avatars earlier if you die
while you're in the Avatar State you
won't reincarnate and it will end the
Avatar cycle but just in general avatars
can be killed like any other person
being in the Avatar State doesn't make
them invincible it just gives them a
great deal more power it was a huge
moment for the show because we're
talking about Nickelodeon here you don't
expect them to kill off their main
character in such a moment typically
you expect that from stuff on HBO like
Game of Thrones when they killed off Jon
Snow but even though he came back at the
beginning of book 3 he did legit die for
a little while it wasn't like they were
trying to fake it or he was on the edge
of death he really did die number 2 the
tale of Iroh in his son Lu TEn so Iroh
also one of the best characters in TV
history partly because he also has one
of the most tragic backstories and best
story arcs in TV history and his arc is
very similar to the arc that Zuko goes
on during the main series but Iroh went
through a lot of those motions in the
events set before the series begins so
you have to remember that Iroh was born
as Fire Lord as Ilan's oldest son and he
was first in line to become the next
Fire Lord he was a good soldier a great
general but his devotion to the military
and their conquest of the other four
nations cost him his relationship with
his son Lu Ten and eventually Lu Ten was
killed in battle with the earth nation a
couple years before the beginning of the
series the event caused Iroh to have
the same type of existential crisis that
Zuko has on the main show questioning
his beliefs turning him down the path of
goodness
eventually he joined the order of the
White Lotus and became a force for good
also sort of adding to the nature of
Zuko's family when this was all
happening and he was grieving for his
dead son Ozai used it as an opportunity
to usurp iroh's place in the line of
succession so that he would jump the
line and become the next Fire Lord
all of iroh's history plays out during
the tales of Ba Sing se episode during
book 2 it's one of the best episodes of
the series and one of the best episodes
of any television show in history a lot
of you may have guessed my number one
so number one the story of what
happened to Zuko's mother
Zucco's backstory is all the more tragic
because his mother's backstory is also
just as tragic one of the reasons why
Zuko's mother is really special is
because she was descended from the line
of Avatar Roku Avatar Roku was married
he had a family with children before he
was killed by his former friend Fire
Lord Sozen
like they say sozin's comet sozin's son
as Alon who's the father of Fire Lord
Ozai forced ursa to marry Ozai in order
to fill a prophecy about a royal
descendent bringing great power to their
family's bloodline Fire Lord
Aslan assumed that this was literal
power and mixing the blood of his family
with the blood of the former avatars
family would do that so Ursus already
forced into an unhappy marriage when
she's young she's constantly mistreated
by Ozai who slowly becomes more and more
evil with his desire for power and world
domination until eventually she winds up
killing Fire Lord
Aslan after she finds out that he had
ordered Ozai to kill Zuko she makes a
bargain to spare Zuko's life with Ozai
in exchange for her going into hiding
for the rest of her life in banishment
and because Zuko was so young she didn't
really get the chance to explain why all
this was happening or say goodbye to him
before she left
so later Ozai lied to Zuko about why she
left making him think that she had
abandoned him as a child because she
didn't love him
adding to the tragedy of his backstory
it does have a bit of a happy ending she
was eventually able to find happiness
maybe I'll do a future video about what
happened to Zuko's mother they kind of
deal with that during the comics though
after the main series and even though it
didn't fit on my top 10 list we do have
to talk about Katara blood bending one
of the most moments I hope they're
able to do that justice when they get to
the live-action version but everyone let
me know what your favorite moment
from Avatar The Last Airbender and leave
all your requests for Avatar bonus
videos click here to learn about their
original plans for Avatar The Last Airbender season 4
when they thought that they were going to do season 4 and
click here for all my new Mandalorian
and baby Yoda season 2 videos thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome happy new year!